after growing up in hard times in West
Virginia walls became an entertainment
reporter covering the famous until she
joined that club herself with the
publication of her Memoir The Glass
Castle sold more than 6 million copies
and was adapted into that film Wall's
new book hang the Moon published by
Simon Schuster a part of Paramount
Global took eight years to write though
it deals with some of the same themes of
family neglect and ultimately
Triumph
A very wise man once said to me said
secrets are a little bit like vampires
they suck the life out of you but they
can exist only in the darkness once
they're exposed the light there's a
moment of horror but then poof they lose
their power and I've just found that to
be very true that these things that
haunted me for so long they're now just
something that happened to me
Jeanette Walls started Living her life
in the light as she wrote The Glass
Castle
shortly after it became a mega
bestseller
she left New York City
he spent half your life here I spent a
long time half my life that's right
we met walls at the back room said to be
one of only two prohibition era
speakeasies still operating in New York
A fitting location for the subject of
her latest novel one she's been
fascinated with since childhood my
father was a raging alcoholic and I
thought I wanted to live in this
wondrous time called prohibition where
it was illegal everywhere to drink and
Mom said oh no it was horrible it was a
complete disaster it backfired all
horribly and I didn't believe her but
then I started reading up on it she was
absolutely right hang the Moon is set
during that time in the same part of
Virginia walls now calls home
it tells the story of a young girl named
Sally Kincaid who's exiled by her father
before returning to help run the family
bootlegging business I love the story of
this woman who survives and prospers
Against All Odds but at a great price
writing fiction did not come easy to
walls though she was no stranger to it
growing up
she describes her parents as fabulous
Liars who had a relationship of
convenience with the truth any
journalist or biographer or Memoirs
knows that we choose our truths that we
select what we tell and how to tell it
anybody who's answered the question how
was your day chooses which truth to tell
do we talk about the guy who cut us off
in traffic or the lovely store clerk who
told us to have a great day and I'm just
now trying to understand the degree to
which you can tell the truth and make
things up at the same time which is what
my father would always say so it's a
little scary to me to do that I've
crossed over into the dark side of
making things up well says her father in
addition to being an alcoholic was
likely bipolar her mother and artist
also battled mental demons
they move their family around the
country sometimes at a moment's notice
before finally settling in West Virginia
at 17 walls escaped to New York City and
after putting herself through college
became an entertainment reporter I was
one of those people who viewers love to
hate stick in a microphone in the face
of the celebrities asking who designed
their albums
yeah
that was me
I'm like huh this isn't kind of this
isn't the kind of Truth telling I
thought I was gonna do
can we just talk about the laugh for a
second sorry
um it's my favorite thing it really is
oh thank you I can't help it
Well's parents eventually followed her
to New York where they lived in
abandoned buildings with other squatters
uh we've been living there about six
years this footage of her parents is
from the 1989 documentary how to squash
a squat my husband was a journalist with
me at New York Magazine he said this
about you that doesn't add up
I use it every time I ask you about your
past you change the topic so I just
changed the topic again he finally he
finally pulled it out of me his first
reaction is that would make a great book
and I honestly thought I honestly
thought I'd get fired from my job did I
just hear you shift from like a clean
accent to like West Virginia or Virginia
you definitely did okay I I
hear it but but the like you let your
guard down my guard down and out comes
the hill but yeah comes the mountain
goat
um so yeah yeah we all have
we all have a lot of personalities but
um you know neither of us is high class
as much as we as much as as much as we
try to be I think we are you know I hear
you
Rex walls died in 1994. Rosemary in
2021.
both have been laid to rest on the
205-acre Virginia Farm walls shares with
her husband journalist John Taylor yeah
long remove from the nomadic lifestyle
of her youth wall says she has no idea
what comes next
and she wouldn't have it any other way
I have no expectations I am so lucky I I
can't believe it sometimes I think I'm
gonna wake up and this will all have
been some kind of a magnificent dream
and I'm still back in West Virginia
without indoor plumbing I I just I can't
believe I have nothing to ask of this
world there's nothing more than I want
or expect I didn't have to write this
this book I didn't have to write hang
the moon it's just life is so dang
beautiful
um and people are so much better than I
thought they were if you give them the
chance to be
I love when she talks about all those
things that happened to her in the past
that used to define her and she just
thought about them all the time but once
they're brought out into the light and
they're exposed now they're as she says
they're just things that happen to her
and she is so joyous despite or maybe
because of what she's gone through I
also thought it was interesting that she
says you choose your your own truth and
what you tell yeah what how was your day
today are you going to talk about the
person who cuts you off and you got
really mad are you going to talk about
the wonderful store clerk who helped you
out you choose your truth she's been
through a lot I can't wait to read this
book that was a great story it's good
and we were talking about I mean
everybody knows The Glass Castle at this
point but yeah and the laugh of course
and the laughs and that's last top five
laugh of all time